joining us now one of the top
quarterback prospects in this year's
draft class chris sims has him
at number four ahead of guys like justin
fields and trey lance here he is texas a
m quarterback
kellenbond kellen welcome in how are you
pal i'm doing great getting ready for
the draft and i appreciate you having me
well and it's great to talk to you i've
heard so many good things about you from
chris sims i decided i got to talk to
this guy myself because you know
sometimes
sims doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about i have a feeling though in
this case
he knows what he's doing i got a trivia
question for you though
before we get started are you ready for
it yes sir
okay you are one of three scc
quarterbacks with more than 9 000 career
passing yards and more than 1500
rushing yards can you name the other two
uh i i think it was dak prescott and tim
tebow
ding ding ding ding ding all right
you're one for one there won't be any
other trivia questions but that's good
you nailed it
yeah that's that's pretty good company
in a division like the sec a conference
more specifically like the sec so
congratulations on that accomplishment
congratulations on all you've done
i'm also curious you grew up in san
antonio kind of caught in no man's land
between the texans and the cowboys
did you favor one or the other growing
up or some other team
uh i didn't i didn't really have teams
growing up uh andre johnson was my
favorite player
uh growing up for for whatever reason it
was a receiver
but i never i never had teams growing up
so
who was the first quarterback that you
patterned yourself after
uh i would probably say uh deshaun
watson
was really the main one and so i was
able to kind of watch him
you know kind of throughout high school
whenever i was you know about to kind of
get in the high school ranks and then
um you know when i was kind of going
through all my recruiting clemson was
one of the places i went to and
just kind of being able to watch him and
things like that was it was amazing
what was the big factor for you to go to
texas a m
i think me just being able to play in
the sec was huge
uh me being able to stay closer to home
and you know
with me uh my support system and you
know my family is huge so being able to
give them the opportunity to travel to
all the games and
um just really to play for an amazing
fan base and an
incredible stadium against the best
competition so
um you know looking back at it four
years later i definitely could say i
feel like i made the right decision
and this is a very common
theme for me but this is the first time
you and i have talked so i'm going to
try it out on you as well you got to
pick
where you went to college a week or so
from now you're going to get thrust into
this blender
that's going to tell you where you're
going what's your anxiety
level with this reality that currently
you don't know we don't know no one
knows
where you're going to be living and
working a week from now
uh i mean i really don't have anxiety
levels um
maybe draft night but you know i'm you
know i i put in the work and
no really for uh 19 years you know since
i started throwing the football so
uh you know at this point it's just the
waiting game and you know i'm going to
be blessed and you know whatever team
drafts me is going to be blessed to have
my presence and um
you know i can't wait to just go into
the facility you know learn a new
playbook and just being able to
have something new in a new city and
interact with new people
russell wilson once told the story that
he put the names of all teams in a hat
pulled one out and it was the seattle
seahawks and lo and behold
that's who drafted him have you done
anything like that do you have any
secret list of teams and i don't expect
you to share it but do you have
you got to have some preference if you
got to pick where you would go which
team it would be right
uh you know i don't have any preference
and you know i
i actually have you know no idea
obviously where i'm going but you know i
kind of like what russell wilson did
and uh you know i may i may try that and
then if it ends up you know working out
then
that'll definitely be a story i tell
once i get drafted
i know the other thing guys do they get
on madden and they create themselves as
a player
and they start throwing on all the
different uniforms have you done that
no i have not yet try it out you got a
week you got some time to kill
get on the map and see how you look
those different uniforms because you
will be wearing one of them
soon what will you be doing on draft
night uh i'll be at my house and
um obviously you know i don't know what
day i'm gonna be picked but you know i'm
gonna have you know
pretty much my whole entire support
system from family to friends and
uh you know former teammates uh who are
at texas a m with me so
uh it's gonna be a truly blessed feeling
and just you know
at that time you know uh we're just
playing the waiting game and
we're gonna see what team drafts me i
would imagine one of the hardest things
to peg
kellen is which pick
is the one where you start thinking
it could be now and then when that
window opens
and then when that window gets to the
point where
okay when's it gonna happen when's it
gonna happen do you have a sense of your
your high and your low
where where you think you could be
drafted the highest
and that point at which if it doesn't
happen
something will have gone seriously wrong
uh
you know some i somewhat do i you know i
guess i can have an idea but
you know with kind of how the draft
works you know you really have no idea
going into it
and you know teams are even though you
know teams may be high on you they may
be higher on another player who they
didn't think was you know going to be
available at that time so
uh you know like i said i'm i'm blessed
to be able to
be in this opportunity and you know
whatever team drafts me is going to be
blessed
will you be a guy like tom brady was 21
years ago who comes out of this process
if you go lower than you think you
should
with a permanent chip on your shoulder
extra motivation to do even more to
prove people wrong who passed on you
uh you know i think no matter where i go
i'm always trying to prove
people my worth whether those are the
people that believed in me or you know
didn't believe in me um you know i don't
think that
with me having an extra chip on my
shoulder if i go later or you know if i
go higher then i shouldn't have a chip
on my shoulder
i'm always gonna be self-motivated and
um you know i if i
you know i think if it doesn't come
within then you know it's not true
motivation then
um so you know i like i said um being
able to play four years and be able to
be able to learn
from you know so many different
experiences has definitely made me the
player and you know also the man that i
am today
do you get more motivation from fear of
failure
or from reaction to criticism
fear failure or reaction to criticism
uh you know i think in my earlier in my
earlier years
um you know i would probably say a
little bit of both um
you know especially my junior year just
um my fear of failure but
you know i think as i continue to grow
and you know part of my growth from my
junior to my senior year is just
um you know my my growth comes from me
just wanting to be better
than you know myself you know the day
before and so you know i was able to
find different ways within practice and
games to
um you know continue to push myself you
know intrinsically and you know
inside um that no you know a lot of
people really
haven't been able to tap into that type
of mindset
so you know like i said there's a
there's a lot of different things that
i've been able to learn over the years
and
um you know like i said if if your
motivation doesn't come within then you
know i don't think it's you know true
motivation
who's giving you the best advice
calendar get ready for
this next level in your career and what
was the advice that they gave you
you know i i would probably say the one
advice that kind of um
you know made me who i am today was you
know my dad probably
um you know right out the womb but you
know whenever i was born um
he you know constantly always said you
know never let anybody out work you
and so um you know it sounds so basic
and so cliche but you know
for me to be able to carry that with me
um you know
pretty much every single day 24 7 and
just you know
make that my type of way of life and you
know my type of
individual culture that's you know
that's something that has always stayed
with me
and you know it's going to stay with me
pretty much until the day that i die
um you know not just on the football
field but you know pretty much anything
that i do in life you know i'm never
gonna let
anybody out work me before we got
started it was obvious to me that you're
very comfortable with the zoom
setting and it occurred to me you've
probably been doing this a lot with nfl
teams how many of the teams did you talk
to and who did you talk to the most
uh well i've talked to every nfl team
and you know
that was mostly down at the senior bowl
um you know i don't want to get
into any you know specifics you know i
met with the um
you know mostly the teams who i guess
you would say you know need quarterbacks
um
but um you know just me being able to
kind of meet with them
you know for me has been an amazing
feeling and you know i tell a lot of
people
that i'd rather be you know meeting with
nfl teams over you know
football and you know my strengths
weaknesses and just being able to talk
ball um instead of you know writing
papers you know still in college or
working on a master's so
you know football is you know my bread
and butter and you know the game that i
will forever love and
so just being able to go through this
process has been amazing i don't know if
you noticed yesterday the eagles head
coach nick ceriani
told reporters at a press conference
that he played rock paper scissors with
some of the prospects did you get to
play rock paper scissors with nick
ciriani
no i did not i saw i didn't see that
though
let's do it now then you want to go hey
if you if you want to go
okay you do three and then choose three
then shoes
uh rock paper scissors there we go okay
here we go
rock paper scissors shoot
oh damn it what
i went with paper you got me all right
want to know
one another undefeated you're undefeated
in your nfl career you're undefeated
it'll be that way until whenever you get
on the field and that's another area
where i'm always fascinated with a young
quarterback coming into the league
is it your preference to go somewhere
and sit and learn and watch
and see a veteran like patrick mahomes
did with alex smith four years ago
or do you want to get thrown right into
it and start week one
and get your education by fire
uh you know i think that you know
whatever presents itself
that i'm gonna be prepared and you know
i say that because you know in college i
was the one who was thrown into the fire
so
um i've been able to learn from those
type of experiences
and you know being able to play for four
years so you know obviously the nfl is
different from college but there's
certain things that i can take from you
know what i've learned in college being
thrown into the fire
to you know you know playing in the nfl
and also you know if i was able to sit
behind you know a back
uh of starter or even a veteran um you
know i think just my ability to go in
and you know
wanting to learn and just you know just
being able to
want to grasp as much information as i
can and just really be able to learn so
that when i'm presented with my
opportunity
um then you know i'm i'm you know my
highest ceiling and i'm able to excel at
an elite level
so you know no matter what happens i
think uh i'm gonna be at an elite level
whenever i get on the field and
you know that's my goal and you know
that's the way that i'm always going to
prepare
chris sims and i were brainstorming some
questions today that we would ask if we
were interviewing candidates and i want
to ask you one of the ones i came up
with
if you couldn't play football if
football was just gone off the table
nfl fold cfl all the football leagues
are gone
can't play football anywhere what would
you do
uh i mean well these are actually some
of the some of the questions that nfl
teams ask and you know i tell them and
you know my hobbies all involve football
whether you know if i'm not playing
football like on the field or you know
in meetings i'm like watching film or
i'm watching highlights or i'm watching
nfl games so um you know i i really
honestly don't do anything else other
than you know breathe football
and you know that's that's been who i am
and you know that's just
the type of person that i am and you
know i think that just comes from the
love of the game
um you know not just you know just be
being a quarterback and being a football
player but just being able to kind of
take a step back and watch it from
i guess a fan's point of view you know
if i'm able to watch you know tom brady
or drew brees or certain
certain guys like that you got pretty
aggressive coaching from jimbo fisher at
texas a
m how did that help you develop into the
quarterback that you've become
well i think personally uh we're able to
jail
you know at an elite level just because
you know one he's passionate about what
he does and you know he wants the best
out of you know
one himself but players um but also i
want the same you know
um you know excellence out of my own
self and so
you know a lot of people say you know
how how do you deal with coach fisher
but
and i tell a lot of people you know by
the time you know i'm already
he's yelling at me getting in trouble
i've already cussed myself out
i'm already if i throw an interception
and he's waiting for me on the sideline
you know by the time
you know it's in the other person's
hands you know i'm already cussing my
own self out so
you know i i have my own expectations of
myself and
uh you know i look forward to taking
those same expectations to the nfl
how do you think the offense that you
ran at texas a m will
prepare you to deal with an nfl level
offense
uh i mean i think it's it's almost
second to none and
you know i think one just the amount of
stuff that coach fisher puts on my plate
at the line of scrimmage
where you know i have the ability to you
know change my calls and the pass and
the run game you know get in and out of
runs from
one run to another or from a pass to run
or vice versa
um and you know a lot of people you know
they look to the sideline um
you know and you know their coach gives
them the play and but
that wasn't like that with coach fisher
and you know to be able to play in the
offense for three years
um you know i definitely think i'm
prepared for the nfl obviously there's
going to be
some nuances in the nfl and you know
certain things that i have to learn but
you know i would definitely say i'm a a
lot head of the curve than you know most
people coming into this draft
is there a criticism of your game that
really bugs you
uh you know i would think you know a lot
of people still think
um you know i'm inconsistent or i'm
inaccurate and you know i think like if
you really want to be technical everyone
is at
inaccurate or everyone is inconsistent
but
you know the goal of being a quarterback
is to limit that inconsistency so
um you know i think just with myself and
you know a lot of people compare my
florida game to
um you know my lsu game which you know i
would definitely say it was
inconsistent um but a lot of people you
know they they don't
have that same exact standard for you
know other guys in
this draft like justin fields where you
compare northwestern versus you know his
clemson game and
you know that's not me bashing anybody i
think it's just me you know being able
to tell the truth and
um you know the same way i'm able to
tell the truth about you know justin
fields
you know i'm i'm going to be
self-critical and tell you that um you
know me
in florida versus lsu was inconsistent
so um
you know i think you know in this draft
i'm definitely held to a
slightly different standard and um just
because of you know the way that i
started
uh in college football you know with me
being inconsistent
um but you know i definitely think you
know i've i've been able to find you
know ways to be more consistent
and be accurate and still um you know
push the ball down the field
so you think that that inconsistency
from early in your college career is
still dragging you down a little bit
now 100
and that would seem to be one of those
and i say this all the time if there's a
concern that a team has about a guy
fine don't take him let someone else
take him maybe somebody in your division
will take him and you'll get to deal
with him twice per year do you kind of
feel that way if someone's going to shy
away from you
because of things from early in your
college career they're going to get what
they deserve if they pass on you
uh you know i think in some ways i could
think like that but
you know i think whenever i get to the
nfl you know i'm not necessarily
you know wanting to be uh you know
quarterbacks who
um go ahead of me um you know i want to
be everybody and you know that's my
mindset going
into the nfl and you know it doesn't
matter if you were drafted ahead of me
before me or you know if a nfl
quarterback ranked ahead of me you know
i'm
my goal no matter what is to you know
one prepare myself but also prepare my
teammates to you know go out and win
you mentioned that you were a fan of
andre johnson when you were young
who's the guy playing today that when
you walk out onto the field and you see
him
there in uniform in the flesh not on tv
you're gonna freak out
i mean i don't think i'm gonna freak out
um but i would probably say the two
people
um well not anymore drew brees uh that
was definitely one person
um but tom brady um and i think you know
a lot of people i don't know necessarily
how this statement will go by you know i
think tom brady is the best athlete of
all time
and you know a lot of people you know
would probably you know say michael
jordan or you know multiple other
different sports but you know i think
there's one there's one
thing about being a quarterback and you
know also being a
offensive player in in the nfl and for a
quarterback
you have to get 10 other guys on the
same page as you um
you know whether if you're uh a track
athlete um or you're a basketball player
you know you know lebron james can you
know he may be able to win a
championship
um with him doing it all on his own um
to a certain extent but you know tom
brady
um just show what he's been able to done
be able to do on you know
um two different teams and get you know
everybody on the same page and go out
and win super bowls
um it's truly amazing to see what he's
been able to do and so
one just me being um you know a lover of
the quarterback position but also you
know a fan and just watching him and
being able to learn from him that that's
definitely uh
that's definitely a person i would like
to meet and kellen that's an
excellent point because you do have
10 teammates who are on the field when
you're on the field then you've got all
your other teammates
who play defense who are on the field
when you're not then you've got your
specialists got all these different
personalities
and people get into the argument as to
whether or not quarterback
wins should count whether it should be a
stat
and i don't think it's nearly as
important as passing statistics but i'm
a firm believer
that a great leader is going to get
more out of his teammates than a guy who
isn't
and a guy like tom brady shows up in
tampa bay gets all those guys like you
said on the same page
that means something and the people who
get caught up in numbers and this idea
that well there's all these other moving
parts
if you've got that personality if you've
got that leadership ability
you are going to lift everyone and that
does count for something and i think
that that's influencing your position
greatest athlete of all time
because it's not just what he does it's
what he gets everyone around him to do
exactly and you know i think a lot of
people you know when they look at
leadership you know it's somebody who's
just you know constantly yelling or
cussing but you know i think one of the
one of the traits that you know i think
i embody that you know i've also been
able to expound on and you know learn is
just
poise you know you look at tom brady
you know you know just watching him this
past super bowl
you know every time the camera was
panned to him you know he was just on
the sideline looking down you know he
wasn't rattled
um you know it doesn't matter if you
know good things were happening or bad
things were happening
you know he's just constantly always
poisoned so you see that when he's able
to get onto the field it doesn't matter
the down and distance
you know that translate over to his
confidence and uh
you know that's you know i feel like
that's a huge reason why he's been able
to have success and he continues to have
success
yeah i agree with you completely and who
knows when it's going to stop you're
so early in your career and
the last thing you're going to be
thinking about is how long you're going
to play in the nfl but when we see a guy
like tom brady
who's going to be 44 this year it really
does suggest to me
that this new age of quarterbacks these
young guys now
you know it used to be 35 to 40 that was
the window when it was done it feels
like it's now 40 to 45 and we're going
to see a lot of guys
playing into their 40s as the years go
by yeah i mean
you know with me uh you know i i don't
know when i'm going to stop playing
the uh in the nfl uh you know but you
know i would definitely probably say
that you know my body is going to have
to be broken down to a certain level
where you know i can't even play in the
nfl you know i
i love the game and you know i love
everything um from preparation
uh to you know getting you know making
sure my teammates are ready and you know
that's part of preparation and
you know just being able to uh every
year you have to reinvent yourself you
know no matter if you're
in college or if you're in the nfl each
and every year you know tom brady
um and even all the greats have to
reinvent their self you know guys are
always
trying to find ways to uh to stop them
and you know so them just being able to
evolve and you know continue to get
better and you know that's just certain
things that i
that i felt like i had to study um and
you know another reason why
i feel like i've made um the jumps that
i made uh
you know going into my senior year just
being able to learn from you know elite
level guys like that
when was the moment that the switch
flipped for you
internally and you recognized you know
what
i'm good enough at this sport to make it
to the nfl
uh you know i think at a young age and
you know i think just i understood the
talent level that i had
and um but i think each year in college
it presented something
um new to me and i was able to learn you
know from different experiences
and you know you know i talked a lot
about you know in my opinion i took a a
step back
um you know from my sophomore to my
junior year you know my junior season
and you know i it was only you know a
lot of people would kind of debate that
you know maybe my junior season was
better
but you know certain expectations that i
had and you know from my sophomore year
that i expected to be
my junior year and so but i always tell
a lot of people sometimes you have to go
back you know a little bit just to go
forward and there were certain learning
experiences um you know that you if i
didn't experience those certain things
my junior year that i may not be where i
am today
um mentally and physically so um you
know there was there was a lot of uh
uh self analyzation and you know self
awareness that went in
uh went into it you know my you know
throughout quarantine i would say then
leading up to fall camp and
you know i think a lot of people
whenever i got back to campus saw you
know
i was i was a lot different and you know
won the way i talked but
um just you know my mental approach and
you know where uh
you know where i was trying to go um at
an elite level and you know i don't
think it's any surprise that you know
one i was able to have my best season
but
um you know i was able to lead um you
know in all sec schedule to a team
nine and one and then you know end up
going into uh
you know having a tremendous senior bowl
and then having a tremendous pro day
give me the one moment one moment from
your time
at texas a m that you're the most proud
of
why can i have two sure uh you know i
think one
uh was the orange bowl this past year my
last college game
and i think it was just more of a uh a
weight off my shoulders and just kind of
understanding what i've been through my
whole entire college career
and uh just you know battling so much
adversity
and just being able to overcome
everything and just
also understanding you know what i meant
to my teammates you know so many
teammates walking up to me and
you know even you know uh guys who were
able to see me from my junior year to my
senior year just like kind of looking at
me like
they told me you know i don't know how
you did it and so um
just kind of understanding the type of
respect that i had from from my team and
just knowing what type of weight was off
my shoulders
um you know knowing at that time you
know i was going to the nfl
and just you know understanding where i
was you know at my freshman year and you
know where this program was
at texas a m my freshman year to you
know getting them to you know number
four in the country
and uh you know a potential spot to be
even be able to play in the playoffs and
you know anything can happen in the
playoffs
um so that was definitely one of them
and then i think
the other one was the florida game this
past year and i think just from a
confidence level from
you know myself my team you know my past
three years i've been just constantly
battling trying to overcome you know
certain things how to
learn how to win in big games um you
know
from playing in the top teams you know
my freshman year uh my sophomore year
junior year and you know just never you
know coming so close in certain games
and even just getting blown out in
certain games but
uh just and also just being able to play
you know another guy who's you know
another quarterback in this draft who
was a
elite talent and then another elite
offense on the other side of the ball
and just you know
uh didn't matter what you know what
obstacle presented itself you know i was
going to go out and win
and so just i think that was kind of a
catapult um
from you know myself you know my
confidence level
um you know my truly um tested my poise
and you know even though you know just
to show kind of we were down in that
third and fourth quarter and just to
come back and win like that and so
um i would definitely say you know that
kind of propelled us to
you know what type of season that we're
gonna have
so the way that we finished it was it
was definitely no surprise to any of us
on the team
last question for you and i appreciate
so much your time but this is the most
important question
of the interview are you ready i'm ready
are you ready to go double or nothing or
are you going to rest at 1-0 at rock
paper scissors
let's do double enough right here we go
ready ready here we go rock
paper scissors shoot
where is it what you got i got paper one
ah-ha we're one and one
take it i'll take it unless you want to
unless do we have to have a rubber match
here or are we good
yeah we we can't add one-on-one all
right one more time here we go
rock paper scissors shoot
ah the rock crushes the scissors
and wins the series i wish you all the
best you're a great guy
we're proud of what you've done at texas
a m and we can't wait to see what you do
in the national football league and i
hope we
will be talking to you many times in the
coming years callum thanks so much for
spending your time today
yes sir i appreciate you for having me
all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports